car et vo voilà l'histoire d'un reçu 7 4
7 qui est beaucoup plus drôle cynique à
celle de ben laden faut bien le dire
et voilà cette cassette est en vente
vous savez quand on fait les enfants
et même ma vie va le faire regarder
aller danser
voilà donc il s'agit des meilleurs
moments de la grosse émission sur cette
cassette
et puis nous avons découvert après
enquête que vous prépariez un long
métrage avec monsieur dominique farrugia
oui je salue ici voilà et vous passez
votre temps finalement apprendre le
septième art d'une certaine façon mais
pointent surtout quand on écrit enfin
sans faire trop de fautes d'orthographe
c'est vraiment difficile mais au travail
et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup bourg